good morning John where do I stand here
yeah you know I seem a little dark I
look great we switch places I bet you
look a little dark okay hot horse Ian
well you know we're here in Los Angeles
together for the dftba.com annual
meeting yeah we're talking to all the
people who helped make that that website
work if you need t-shirts posters mugs
plushies keychains check out dftba.com
I'm a little concerned that you might be
graying a little bit in the temples now
I know that I am all I'm full grip you
are I am out in any way full gray I am
the oldest youtuber no I am the last
living American youtuber my last living
American you don't know a true thing
John yes we talked about an episode of
dear Hank and John in the past
that's our podcasts out how there was
there were only two possible multiverse
futures in which Donald Trump became the
Republican nominee and in one of them
you're the worst time and in one of them
it was because it was because a meteor
killed all but 12 Americans well he
still wasn't elected president all right
John we got some questions from people
got questions from snapchat the kid they
snared their questions and that's it to
me some question and now we shall answer
them this question is what is your
favorite form of the potato oh god are
we doing potatoes again no that was I
did not ask for potato this is a
completely unrelated my strongly I have
a strong preference for french fry the
next question is I don't know how to
work my phone do you like snapchat
filters I'm gonna level with you I don't
know how to use snapchat very well but
when I was in Jordan our interpreter
Nita sat down with kids and use snapchat
filters and they were crazy about maybe
reaming they couldn't believe it I was
like actually this is pretty amazing how
cute is this cat on a scale of like 1 to
10 I'm gonna say 8 yeah it's pretty cute
cat the little one in a fight Andrew
Jackson or Seattle Roosevelt can you
just say that right who would win in a
fight Andrew Jackson who should this
young woman condition or shampoo first
always shampoo then condition I never
have heard of condition I didn't even
know that conditioning first was an
option you're just gonna wash out all
the conditioned mint this nerdfighter
ask what vlogbrothers ever do a tour
you should ask because I'm announcing
Hank green and the perfect strangers
tour today right now it's happening I
drew bounced it Wow where you guys go
we're going to all of these places there
I didn't have to remember alright great
so you can also look at the link in the
description now tickets all the tickets
are available now yeah they're
inexpensive
we're not that popular and then Hank and
I will hopefully go on tour sometime
next year together what's your favorite
food to eat when you're sick you know
it's an old favorite and I know a lot of
people feel this way but I just I really
enjoy Korres septic max oh yeah
high-calorie right into the back of the
throat where that where the strep is and
it just makes it not hurt smells like a
doctor's office favorite Taylor Swift
song we're gonna do it on three ready
one two three
shake it off how's the book writing job
thanks for asking
woman with anglerfish it's going I'm
writing what word are you on you mean
the last word that I wrote I'll look
found it I found the word the word is
coffee alright I know a little bit about
your book it includes stirring milk into
morning coffee no less oh do you think
that that line is gonna make it 50/50
alright got another question John can
you show us your sock yes if you were a
kitchen appliance what would you be I'd
be a toaster oven you want to ask why
not really well there's really no reason
I just love toaster ovens maybe an oven
is I'm reliable and I'm hot you are a
reliable hot and inexpensive that's
right very sorry Oh Hank I will see you